c'est bien ce que je pensais personnes
voire dix bonnes minutes que casimir on
a dû venir me servir montée il n'est pas
là je suis sûr que cet individu presto
reliques et dans le jardin en train de
faire sa sieste
kazemi
casimir
quoi qu'est-ce que c'est enfin tu n'as
pas honte de me réveiller au plein
milieu de ma siège tant qu
eu du mal à
l'indignation je suis mal voilà
d'indigestion alors ça ne m'étonne pas
parce qu'un
paix s'il
d'indignation voilà je suis indigné
scandalisé choqué de l'entendre protesté
alors que presque tous les jours c'est
toi qui me réveille pendant masia ben
oui oui parce que je ne peux pas faire
autrement et pourquoi ça pour qu'on
danse yeux par ce côté sieste dure toute
la journée je n'ai jamais vu quelqu'un
d'aussi fini encore renard à goethe
interdit d'insulter les renards ce sont
des animaux vif intelligent rusé qui
doivent lutter dans la forêt pour
assurer la maigre subsistance de leurs
familles bon d'accord ne te mets pas en
rage pour si peu
tu l'as dit 3i
monstruosité marqué ce que j'ai dit
encore
la rage tue va prétendre toi aussi que
ce sont les renards qui sont les seuls
responsables
et bientôt on offrira de l'argent à
celui qui rapportera ma peau
je serai pourchassé par les chasseurs
obligé de fuir dans les bois ou même de
quitter l'île comme passager clandestin
enfin un peu trop un personne ne vous
tapez au lit on à se mettre en rage et
est une expression qui vous dire se
mettre en colère c'est tout on aime
beaucoup trop pour peut vouloir du mal
merci casimir en tuer un véritable ami
mais dis moi si tu même temps que ça
ouais pourquoi tu laissais passer
l'heure de monter alors que c'est ton
tour de le préparer mais ce n'est pas
encore l'heure
regarde
là je ne comprends plus alors
mon réveil ne marche plutôt pas le
moindre aux tic tac tu as encore oublié
de remonter
non non il est remonté à fond il ya
peut-être une aiguille tordus qui coince
l'autre nom et les deux aiguilles sont
bien droite entre moi ce réveil
voir
sa mère de marché pourtant
je suis un très bon horlogerie nora mais
ce n'est pas une horloge c'est un réveil
en minant casimir je sais mais lorlanges
est une personne qui répare les horloges
les révèlent les monges les pendules à
temps je pourrais très attention mais
oui mais oui ici tout va bien là on s'y
met tous mahler en place je ne vois plus
qu'une méthode sa vente
efficace surtout
regarde elle mais tu es fou non
moi ça marche il marche ouais ça conclut
un horloger formidable est ce que tous
les horlogers emploie la méthode a ramé
exactement
ouais c'est un métier extraordinaire
j'aimerais bien être hors logement vous
et n'hésite pas à casimir il ya sûrement
plein de montrer de pendule qui ne
marche pas dans l'île aux enfants c'est
vrai ça moi je viens les voir merci
casimir tu n'oublies pas un seul coup
comme ça ouais comme ça kaka provost
merci pas tout à leur travail bien et
sa luge
s'ennuierait vraiment de m'appeler julie
d'accord juju je t'appellerai julie
c'est quand même
est-ce que tu aurais un réveil ou une
montre a confié aux meilleurs horloger
du monde pourquoi tu connais le meilleur
récit d'humour et très bien même mais
c'est potassique figure toi comment
votre préférée est détraqué écoute tu
m'entends un acheteur jeu velika
chercher d'accord je garde le kiosque
elle va vraiment être surprise quand
elle saura que le meilleur horloger du
monde c'est moi
je lis
je les ai aimés oui oui julie elle est
partie mais elle revient dans un instant
or quelle malchance alors je voulais lui
demandé un cachet d'aspirine tu les
malades g j'ai pris un coup de soleil et
j'ai très très mal à la tête prend un
coup devient l'âge assieds toi je vais
m'occuper de poids alors merci casimiro
sur tâche et si vous savez ce journal oh
la la hâte en
championnat du tout je lis range son
l'aspirine mais je te préparer un petit
remontant au blue bulgare est ici tu
veux au nom non non non non non non
surtout pas de bulle bulgare non je t'en
prie ça ça me tape dans la tête tu veux
pas savoir j'ai l'impression d'avoir
d'avoir une horloge or c'est une horloge
entre russes c'est le sens du comprend
il arrive comme ça et ça c'est un petit
peu comme comme un tic-tac de l'horloge
est une blanche dans la tête je crois
que le moment est venu pour moi de
montrer mes talents de plus grand
horloger du monde
ne bouge pas françois je vais trouver
quelque chose je vais arranger ça
raul a
jamais eu aussi mal car on regarde
devant toi pourquoi il rien on ne bouge
plus bien droit qu attend
ça va mieux bon genre je te laisse un
petit acheter
c'est formidable je suis vraiment plus
grand horloger du monde à
au
musée puise mais que vous arrivez
mademoiselle [ __ ] vous enfin casimir
félicite mois plus tôt je viens de
réaliser le record de lille en moins de
deux heures attend une 52 minutes 43
secondes exactement vous êtes sûr quand
on reprend montrait bien à leurs amants
mon chronomètre fonctionne parfaitement
mais c'est mon coeur qui ne va plus du
tout il va peut-être comme une âme on
prend qui avança si tu veux ça peu près
ça alors jusqu il faut pour vous ne
bougez plus vous irait beaucoup mieux je
vais arranger ça
ne bougeait plus regarder devant vous
oui comme ça tu veux voilà voilà voilà
ça va mieux
bon eh bien tant mieux je vous laisse
avec eux font soir
je coure annoncé la bonne nouvelle à
julie
oh
oh là là
où il ya peu de courage chers et demi un
peu de courage c'est presque terminé
épingle
j'ai de plus en plus mal aux ailes
futaies et si au moins ainsi au moins je
comprenais ce qui m'est arrivé
attendez oui casimir était à côté de moi
et un moment il est passé derrière il
m'a demandé de regarder droit devant moi
moi aussi maintenant je me souviens il
m'a demandé de regarder devant moi et
après plus rien
d'après un éclair
un éclair et puis rien jusqu'à ce que
vous veniez me réveiller un éclair mais
alors qu'est si bien qu'à signer mais
j'ai devenu fou quasi midi et nous
assommer au françois
mais regardez là bas casimir et julie au
en mai françois il faut la prévenir tout
de suite mais elle est en danger cette
petite et vous avez raison et armés mais
surtout il faut faut pas que casimir
nous voir or nous avons essayé de
prévenir je lis et ce pendant deux
minutes elle marchera à merveille le la
bible
[Musique]
et attention à toi j'ai dit vous êtes en
danger j'avais peur en danger
protège-moi jolie où elle danger je lis
mes essais casimir qui est dangereux
mois nous qu'il nous a attaqués oui la
jument par derrière qui a sommé tous les
9 du primaire c'est fou j'ai simplement
voulu les soigner par la méthode du
meilleur horloger du monde ah oui parce
que c'est toi le meilleur horloger du
monde il ya une méthode un peu spécial
lui n'avait tendent à faillible
d'ailleurs vous allez voir regarder
j'aurais réparer la montre de julie
regardez bien
et voilà onze ans ça ça n'a pas marché
pour nos têtes non plus
attendez attendez ce n'est pas grave je
sais l'erreur que j'ai fait excusez moi
et quelle est cette erreur eh bien je
crois que je n'ai pas tapé au bon
endroit
c'est l'enfant je voulais seulement les
guérir